hey let's go brass body in fish pan
today I got a tweet from Adam Adam Adam
Adams
yeah stea he made this list called top
10 weirdest website and he linked in to
me and I'm like that seems like a great
video and I like the idea that you bros
help me with videos uh so Thank You Adam
let's begin with number 10 Kubo dot CC /
creepy girl Oh for sake
she's following the my mouse pointer I
feel like she's gonna jump scare me I
don't trust God please don't smush who
made this and why how's it going bros
Myers
number nine student ology net / Tuesday
it just says no okay well I'm weirded
out watching grass grow calm oh great ha
ha ha these things oh my god I
remember when I was younger I try to
make websites and this is pretty much
how every website ever used to look
amazing so this is a live webcam
of grass growing updated every two
seconds number seven zoom quilt org all
right this looks weird already what is
this Oh God where are you taking me
okay we're going in we're going inside
okay how much can we zoom Jesus Christ
follow the lizard tongue oh god they
have holes in them
it's gonna be at the end I'm not sure I
wanted to go
this is tripping me the out had it
had it at okay let me tell us how does
this work out of science work stop
zooming geez Oh God
oh Widow it's getting weird man
I'll never these times oh my god
my brain can not keep up with this shape
sake
maybe it's just so much to process
and icky over before you like oh yeah
that was it oh my god
oh I need a minute number six is it not
the webcam oh great it's another one of
these watching paint dry web cam I can
move the camera amazing
number five snap bubbles calm this
should be good number four alien
abductions calm okay what the is
this thousands of individuals are
abducted by aliens each year who do the
aliens choose and why haven't they
chosen you okay what the they offer
up alien objections
is that it why even invest the time
trouble and expense involved in an
actual abduction when the highly-trained
professional staff at alien abduction
Incorporated can provide you with
personal realistic memories of alien
abductions that you have been waiting
for your entire life
number three no backup
all right let's check it out instead no
button press in dire situations
that's my reaction students website
you know and that one
number one the nicest place on the
internet I've seen this one before and
it's it's it is what it is I guess
it's a bunch of strangers hugging you
there it is that's my man give it up
here yeah yeah it's weird
I don't want to hug you sorry no condos
time oh no yes mama Faramir man
yeah that's right ah
is that Sam stripping the fun alright
Sam here yup
I went throwing weights that's awkward
okay I'm not gonna have you okay you
scare me you scare me
you scare me I've taken in your bottle
you'll slap calm oh my god I've seen
this one this one is one of my favorite
websites yes right
the epicenter of the Internet
this is supposed to be the weirdest
subreddit yep
you win all right Chris we're gonna at
the end that episode there they would
like do you want me to do more of these
tough weird web sites and I'll check
them out
Thank You Adam for submitting it
click here for more and I'll see you
Bros in the next episode see I'm giving
you don't come out don't deny my yoga
belt you an acceptance by lollipop
cookies popcorn that's